est-ce que vous avez cherché à le jouer
si aisément puisque c'est justement
l'occasion de ses contacts qui m'ont été
remises ensuite en pleine phase sur
twitter où on dit regardez le policier
qui le soutiennent donc vous avez
manifesté dès le départ tout mon soutien
pour faire face à la disparition de sa
femme qu'il aimait profondément et pour
laquelle il a été beaucoup atteint
normal et ça on peut retrouver un les
captures d'écran si vous le mettez en
doute est normal je vais pas non mais
voilà moi j'étais le soutenir par
rapport à ça je lui ai dit que je lui
apporter tout mon soutien pour ce qu'ils
étaient je sais que c'est pas facile la
prise en charge quotidienne de ses
enfants le chagrin qui l'avait les
difficultés d'avoir eu un vrai coup de
coeur pour lui puisque les vu qu'une
fois mais oui c'est ça mais en fait on
peut s'apprend pas apprécié des gens
qu'on n'a jamais vus vous avez alors aux
dés lors on correspond avec eux dès lors
où on les a souvent au téléphone avant
dès lors plus où il m'a aidé moi sur des
aspects techniques de ma vie privée qui
étaient là en l'occurrence ma maison qui
était livré à aider mais des non
conformités
honnêtement je n'ai aucune raison de ne
pas avoir de l'affect pour cette
personne parce qu'elle habite pas dix
mètres de chez moi je peux prendre le
café ils voulaient choses que je
n'aurais certainement pas saisi la cnil
a clamé son innocence auprès de vous ou
pas du tout wi fi vous a dit je suis
innocent et voilà moi il m'a toujours
dit qu'il était innocent et qu'il
n'avait strictement rien à voir avec
l'histoire on n'était pas dans la
provocation et quand il ya un lait et
quand ils racontent plein de choses tout
et tout ce qu'on a entendu ce que vous
l'avez vu depuis oui ça voulait réserver
un moyen de raconter tout ça non parce
qu'en fait par la suite ce qui s'est
passé peu avant son incarcération il a
fermé son compte facebook changer de
numéro de téléphone
et donc j'ai perdu moi tout contact
quelques semaines avant le qu'il soit
incarcéré est ce que je remets en cause
sur l'incarcération c'est que je pense
qu'une assignation à résidence
surveillance électronique aurait permis
exactement la même chose au niveau de l'
enquête n'aurait pas entravée et lui
aurait permis de rester avec ses enfants
et sa par rapport à l' équilibre des
enfants même eu même je pense que ça
aurait été une grosse plus-value oui je
suis très fier
contradictoire
si c'est lui il est en prison ça veut
dire qu'il y en a a réellement qui est
dehors qui est dangereux et là vous
voulez lui mettre un bracelet
électronique et les adore
il est chez lui dans des limites ça
sonne voyez aucun moment vous n'avez été
ébranlé par les différents éléments qui
a apporté sa l'avocat de la famille
gillard notamment et autant vous êtes
policier oui à aucun moment vous estimez
le travail de vos collègues alors déjà
moi je n'aime pas le travail de mes
collègues puisque la ces magistrats qui
sont cause c'est pas les policiers noyé
par les policiers
il faut d'instructeurs les policiers ils
ont fait leur travail ils l'ont fait
avec des moyens colossaux à qui on est
et vous l'avez dit vous-même avec les
battues avec des moyens qui ont été pris
moi ce que j'observe c'est
qu'aujourd'hui hélas
concrètement s'il y avait de quoi
inculpé à coup sûr cédric dinars il
serait déclarée coupable
tu nous avais mes connaissances pardonne
c'est juste une méconnaissance
procédurale mais on en est au stade de
l'instruction il est inculpé de rien du
tout il est présumé je n'ai pas les
dents leur laddh de l'instruction on
inculque personne ne va pas le condamner
à ce que je voulais mener l'instruction
les gestions et le juge des libertés des
tensions qui fait le placement à titre
préventif penser ça que je mets en cause
là à l'instant t et quand je parle d'art
ce donc d'assignation à résidence
surveillance électronique c'est que je
pense que ce qui aurait été quand même
la solution la plus adaptée les
magistrats mais aussi resté serré les
rangs à dunkerque il veut